[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD: Buck!
BUCKINGHAM: Yeah.
RICHARD: A word
with you, sirrah.
BUCKINGHAM: Dude,
what did you call me?
Stop talking like that.
RICHARD: Well, I have a
philosophical question.
BUCKINGHAM: Oh, I love those.
Go ahead.
RICHARD: OK.
Do think our social
station is circamountable,
or is it immutable?
BUCKINGHAM: Oh, good question.
Immutable.
RICHARD: Uh, no, but
[LAUGHS] don't you
think we can overcome
our circumstance given
sufficient cunning and skill?
BUCKINGHAM: No.
No, I don't.
But I'm not like
you, yearning to fly
beyond nature's
boundaries like some sort
of disabled nerd Icarus.
Anyway, why do you ask?
RICHARD: No reason,
Buckingham, Buck--
Barbie B. It's just that
I've got plans for a date.
BUCKINGHAM: A date?
You?
Who's going to date you?
RICHARD: Well, I was thinking
of grabbing a date to the Sadie
Hawkins.
BUCKINGHAM: Oh, I get it.
You think by going
to the dance, you'll
seem like less of a
creepy Renaissance
bear talking weirdo?
RICHARD: Well, and I'll
rise past by circumstance.
Yes.
BUCKINGHAM: I like it.
I can help if you want.
Oh, do you want to go
with me to the dance?
Not as like a date or whatever,
but as, like, friends?
RICHARD: Hmm.
I'll pass.
BUCKINGHAM: OK,
whatever, jerk face.
It's not like I want to be the
matchy matchy disabled couple.
RICHARD: Fine.
BUCKINGHAM: Fine?
OK.
You do know this Sadie
Hawkins dance is where
the girl asks the guy out.
Right?
And I'm, like, the only
girl that talks you.
RICHARD: That's fine.
I was thinking of
going with Anne.
BUCKINGHAM: Anne Margaret?
But she's the most
popular girl in school.
RICHARD: Formerly
the most popular.
Eddie broke up with
her over winter break.
BUCKINGHAM: So what?
She's still super
out of your league?
RICHARD: Is she, Buck?
Is she?
Or maybe it's just
that you don't
know what league that I'm in.
[TIGHTENS BACKPACK STRAPS]
BUCKINGHAM: No.
She's out of your league.
She's hot.
She's smart.
She's super talented.
You know she's a
quasi-professional dancer?
RICHARD: Oh, but now she's
in wounded bird mode.
See, if I can get her
to ask me to the dance,
then I will instantly bolt past
my current inglorious station--
BUCKINGHAM: No, you won't.
RICHARD: And for once,
people might see me.
BUCKINGHAM: OK.
[LAUGHS] Richard, if you had
to ask Anne to the dance,
that would already be
a humiliating rejection
situation.
But getting her to ask you,
hmm, I mean, what's your angle?
Hypnosis or cash?
RICHARD: Buck.
BUCKINGHAM: Plus why
Eddie's ex-girlfriend?
Is it like a copycat thing,
a revenge thing, a sex thing?
Is it a
sex-revenge-copycat thing?
Wait, Richard, is this a scheme?
RICHARD: What?
BUCKINGHAM: You're
always scheming.
Oh, ah!
Are you running for president?
RICHARD: What?
BUCKINGHAM: Oh, my god.
Is getting a date with Anne
Margaret the first step
in an elaborate multi-step
scheme for getting
elected senior class president?
[GASPS] It is, isn't it?
Confess!
RICHARD: Well, no.
Buck, it's not a scheme.
I just want a date.
BUCKINGHAM: Yeah, and I want
Chris Evans to sit on my face.
Only he has to ask.
RICHARD: Who is Chris--
BUCKINGHAM: Chris Evans
is Captain America.
He's been Captain America
for, like, 19 movies.
I'm sorry, do you watch
movies, or are you
too busy tuning into the
voices inside your head?
RICHARD: [GASPS] Softer now.
She approaches.
BUCKINGHAM: Softer now,
who talks like that?
RICHARD: Away with you, Buck.
BUCKINGHAM: All right.
Whatever, pal.
Follow your dreams.
RICHARD: Well, Buck's
right, of course.
Landing a date
with Anne Margaret
is part of an elaborate
multi-step scheme.
If I can capture
Eddie's ex-girlfriend,
the people will know that I
am the most redoubtable knave,
someone who's not
to be fuck-ed with.
And so, Roseland High School,
prepare for your fate.
My first step to power
is to land a first date.
ANNE MARGARET: Ah!
RICHARD: Oh, Anne.
I believe you have something
you wanted to ask me.
ANNE MARGARET: I did?
RICHARD: Uh-huh, so go ahead.
ANNE MARGARET: Uh, I really
can't think of anything.
Can you get out of my way?
RICHARD: Oops,
no, that's not it.
ANNE MARGARET: I don't
know what your deal is.
But I'm not into
guessing games, Richard.
RICHARD: Oh, this isn't a game.
It's an invitation.
So go ahead.
Invite me to Sadie Hawkins.
All you have to do is ask.
ANNE MARGARET: Oh.
Excuse me.
[CHUCKLES] Look, I know
you're differently abled,
but you got to know
that's not happening.
RICHARD: Uh, but why, Anne?
ANNE MARGARET: Because
I don't like you.
RICHARD: You don't even know me.
I mean, we've known each
other since middle school,
but this is the most
that we've talked.
ANNE MARGARET: You're right.
I don't know you.
So why would I ask you out?
Because I pity you?
RICHARD: Whoa, no one's
asking for pity here.
Why?
Do you pity me?
Or do you fear me?
Are you afraid you'll
contract cerebral palsy just
by the very taint of my touch?
ANNE MARGARET: Quit that.
RICHARD: See?
You hate me for what I am.
ANNE MARGARET: No, I don't.
I just-- Richard, I
don't mean to be mean.
I'm just trying to
stay in my lane here.
You know?
RICHARD: Well,
which is it, Anne?
Pity me, hate me, or fear me?
ANNE MARGARET: I
don't even know you.
I nothing you.
RICHARD: Exactly.
I'm not even relevant here.
See?
The real reason you're going
to ask me to Sadie Hawkins
is because it's the best
way to get back at Eddie.
ANNE MARGARET: Eddie?
But I don't want to
get back at Eddie.
RICHARD: Really?
Even though he was
hardcore dating you
all through winter break,
only to immediately start
dating Liz Woodville?
ANNE MARGARET:
Eddie's dating Liz?
[SCOFFS] No, he's not.
RICHARD: Clearly,
you don't follow
Lix Woodville on Instagram.
ANNE MARGARET: Whatever.
It's done now.
He can date who he wants.
RICHARD: Well, I've seen
you on campus, Anne,
seen the happy-go-lucky social
butterfly cocooning herself
in a chrysalis of
melancholy and doubt.
ANNE MARGARET: Yeah, well,
it's been a really hard year.
RICHARD: Well, which is why it's
so brave of you soldiering on
like this.
You know something, Anne?
I've never known the
tender pleasures of dating.
ANNE MARGARET:
(SARCASTICALLY) Really?
RICHARD: But then
again, I've never
been unceremoniously dumped.
ANNE MARGARET: That--
That's-- is that what
people are saying?
RICHARD: Well,
that's right, Anne.
He's still the most
popular person in school,
whereas you, you
are nothing now.
ANNE MARGARET: I'm not--
I'm not nothing.
I'm just me.
RICHARD: Well, being
you isn't enough,
not in this Roseland wasteland.
If Eddie and Liz
Woodville go to the dance,
what's your counterattack?
ANNE MARGARET: Why do I
even need a counterattack?
I swear to god, high school
drama is such bullshit.
RICHARD: Ask me to the dance.
If you go with me, everyone
will see what a good person
you are, that you did this
selfless good deed of taking
Richard the Cripple to
his very first dance.
I'm your charm offensive.
ANNE MARGARET: OK.
But if I did go
with you, I'd only
be doing it to be a good person.
It doesn't mean that
we're, like, dating.
RICHARD: Well, not yet.
ANNE MARGARET: Not ever.
RICHARD: Not ever yet.
ANNE MARGARET: God, Richard,
what kind of crazy fantasies
go on in that head?
RICHARD: So many, Anne.
You have no idea.
So what's it going to be?
ANNE MARGARET: Fine.
Richard, will you go to
Sadie Hawkins with me?
RICHARD: No.
ANNE MARGARET: No?
You fucking ass crack.
RICHARD: No, I-- I can't go
to the dance with you, Anne,
because I never
learned how to dance.
ANNE MARGARET: Oh.
Well, could I teach
you or something?
I do have a dance background.
RICHARD: It's a date!
ANNE MARGARET: Oh, but it's not.
RICHARD: Oo, spicy, Anne.
Methinks the lady
doth protest too much.
ANNE MARGARET: I think
I'm protesting just right.
RICHARD: Hey, Anne.
ANNE MARGARET: Jesus.
What?
RICHARD: You're a good person.
ANNE MARGARET: Thanks.
RICHARD: Ha!
Did you fucking see that?
Ha, ha, ha.
Was ever woman so easily won?
Whoo!
We're going to be like
Lancelot and Guinevere, Pyramus
and Thisbe, Michelle and Barack.
[APPLAUSE]
GREGG MOZGALA:
I'm Gregg Mozgala.
And I'm playing Richard.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Hi.
[APPLAUSE]
GREGG MOZGALA: Oh, thanks.
That's really nice.
Thanks, Charlie.
Hi,
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
I'm Tiffany Villarin.
And I'm playing Anne Margaret.
[APPLAUSE]
MARINDA ANDERSON:
I'm Marinda Anderson,
and I play Elizabeth, Miss
York, also known as Miss York.
[APPLAUSE]
SHANNON DEVIDO: I'm Shannon
DeVido, and I play Buck.
[APPLAUSE]
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Wonderful.
Well, I hope you all
enjoyed the scene.
I know some people have actually
been to the show already.
If you haven't, go
get your tickets now.
It's selling out really fast.
And they've already announced
an extension actually.
So you can go and get tickets.
So "Teenage Dick" is
a modern retelling
of "Richard III,"
Shakespeare's "Richard III."
You probably recognized
some of the dialogue.
So let's talk about the title.
I know it caused a little
bit of hand-wringing.
Gregg, you actually commissioned
the play from Mike Lew.
GREGG MOZGALA: That's right.
Yeah.
And he mentioned in the video--
it was as simple as that.
I just thought, Mike, I want
you write a "Richard III"
set in high school and
call it "Teenage Dick."
So yeah, so I run a theater
company called The Apothetae.
And we focus on plays that--
we produce works that
explore and illuminate
the disabled experience,
which is really an exploration
to figure out what that is.
And I thought Richard III
is arguably the most famous
disabled character in
Western dramatic literature.
So he's a great character
to take on and explore.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: You
mentioned Apothetae.
Where did that name come from?
GREGG MOZGALA: So
the inspiration,
the namesake of the company,
there was a disabled playwright
named John Belluso, who had
worked in theater extensively
and was also writing for
shows like "Deadwood" on HBO
and some network shows.
He actually passed away in 2006.
And in 2007, I was in
the New York premiere
of a show of his called
"The Rules of Charity,"
and a character actually
mentions the Apothetae, which
was a place in ancient
Sparta in Greece where--
The Spartans were known
for their very fascistic
physical world view.
They were a very
militaristic society.
So if you didn't
fit that worldview,
the Apothetae was a place,
a chasm in the ground,
where disabled and
deformed infants
were left to the elements.
So it roughly translates
to "the place of exposure."
And I'm just like, I thought
that was really beautiful.
And so I'm playing on
that double entendre
to shed light into dark
places and also expose,
or make visible, the
disabled experience,
or make the history of
disabled performance.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: And we
talked a little bit earlier
about authentic casting.
And if we think
about stories that
feature a disabled character,
so often these narratives
fall in a very
few limited number
of buckets, inspirational,
overcoming adversity.
Why do you think
these narratives are
so pervasive in our culture?
GREGG MOZGALA: Whoa.
That's a big question.
Well, I think, again, with this
incredibly representational
cast, right, and I think
that was intentional.
And by partnering
with Ma-Yi, which
is an Asian-American
theater company,
we have this incredible
cast and production
team that is diverse ethnically,
gender, ability, just
all kinds of ways,
which is really great.
And I can't speak on
being Asian-American or
African-American, but from
a disability perspective,
I think disability is
very hard to deal with.
I mean, there's a lot of anxiety
around the issue and the topic
that's not discussed,
or hasn't been discussed
as openly as the experience
of other marginalized groups,
because that work has been
done for decades and decades
and decades now, where
disability is behind
in that regard.
But the pervasive
narratives are being
an inspiration, overcoming
adversity, or death
with dignity.
You know?
And I think those
are the three buckets
that I would put these in.
I don't know, not
to be a downer,
but I think the
context of disability
is not a geographic location
or a specific culture.
Right?
But the context of disability
is illness, trauma, pain,
and death.
So that can be difficult to
deal with because it reminds one
of their own vulnerability
and ultimately,
their own mortality,
I think, which again,
that can be a difficult
pill to swallow.
But I think there's great--
that can be seen as a
deficit, or that can
be seen as a great strength.
Because if someone has undergone
trauma and becomes disabled,
that's difficult, yes.
But the flip side of
that is that they've
had an encounter with
death and beat it.
And I think there's
great strength in that.
And so I'm interested
in focusing
on both the dark, and the light,
and all the spaces in between.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Excellent.
Now you mentioned-- Ma-Yi
is very focused on diversity
and representation in
the arts in general,
not just on stage, but off
stage as well, in the crew,
and in writing and directing.
There's been a lot of
other stories in the media
lately about movies
in particular and TV
and representation
in those roles,
either be it a traditional role
being played by a white actor.
And Chen and I were having
a quick conversation
about this earlier.
And you never want to take
work away from people.
But you also want to be in
control of your narrative
that you identify with.
So how do you guys handle
that in your day to day,
and going the casting calls,
and choosing productions
you work on?
TIFFANY VILLARIN: I think
one of the reasons why
I love being an
actor in New York
is Ma-Yi theater, because
they are the largest
gathering of
Asian-American playwrights
in history in the
country, in the world.
And I feel very fortunate
to be able to have
gotten to know a lot of them,
a lot of those playwrights,
and to be in on the
ground level of new works
that they're creating
because that conversation
about representation.
And about being in
charge of our narratives,
and not having the
narrative always
be about explaining my
race for white people,
frankly, is at the top of that
awareness for those writers.
And it's important work, I
think, to be to be doing.
And Mike is-- he's the--
GREGG MOZGALA: He's the
head of that program, right?
TIFFANY VILLARIN: He's the
head of the Ma-Yi's writers lab
right now.
And I think that this
play in particular
is doing all of those things
on all the different levels,
not just about race, but also
about ability and disability.
GREGG MOZGALA: It
also happens to be
incredibly smart and funny.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: And it's
smart, and it's funny.
And yeah, it's all
those levels of things.
And it's Shakespeare.
So you know, people who laugh
at the funny inside Shakespeare
jokes are like, oh, you're
the Shakespeare nerds.
I hear you.
So it's all in there.
And that's the work that
I want to be involved in
and that I think is
the future of what
audiences want to experience.
That's the possibility.
That where theater could go,
where storytelling could go,
that direction.
Yeah.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Great.
Oh.
Anything you would add?
MARINDA ANDERSON: No,
I agree with that.
Yeah.
I mean, being an actor,
going into these auditions,
a lot of the times,
you do get into a play,
and a lot of the times,
they are not really
welcoming of your experience,
for me, as a black woman
into the room.
I mean it's like, yay,
we want to be diverse.
Yay!
You know what I mean?
Can I also bring
myself into it as well?
And that's not been
this experience at all.
It's so inclusive.
And I feel very welcomed
and feel very represented,
and not in a way
of like, I'm black.
You know what I mean?
Just like, I'm a teacher,
and I'm doing my job.
You know what I mean?
I don't have to explain it.
Like what you were saying, I
don't have to explain what I am
and who I am.
And with this play, it's just--
like you said, it's all there.
It's just brilliant,
and so easy to dive
into and have so much fun.
So I feel very welcome.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Marinda,
you mentioned that you
play the teacher is your work.
So your character-- you
guys really should go
watch the play.
Your character has these
really great moments
where you're cringing
at some of the moments,
and then you're just
laughing out loud.
I'm not going to
give any spoilers.
MARINDA ANDERSON: I'm cringing?
Or you're cringing.
CORRIE DAVIDSON:
You're cringing at some
of the lines and the gestures.
But then toward the
latter end of the show,
you have this
spectacular solo moments,
where I feel like Miss
York really finds her own.
You're also the only adult
in the room, if you will.
Everyone else is a
high school teenager.
So what was it like playing that
adult in such an ensemble show?
MARINDA ANDERSON:
It's funny because I
was like, oh, this is so fun.
It's set in high school.
And I don't actually
know how old everyone is.
I assume we're all
actually the same age-ish.
But I was like, oh, yeah,
we get to play teens.
I'm like, oh, no, I have
to be the adult person.
And it's funny because
I'm also the deputy,
and I'm also the fight captain.
So it's funny how--
CORRIE DAVIDSON: All
the responsibility.
MARINDA ANDERSON:
I, all of a sudden,
became the responsible one,
which is not me as Marinda.
But it's funny how that just
kind of a seeped on over.
But it's been fun.
I've actually never--
GREGG MOZGALA: We
get what we deserve,
and we get what we're ready for.
MARINDA ANDERSON:
Thank you, Gregg.
[LAUGHTER]
I never felt like the
adult in the room,
though, during rehearsal.
I just felt like one of
the clowns just having fun.
So I don't really
feel like the teacher,
I mean, in those
moments of like, oh god,
what, is she doing.
I'm like, oh, that's when the
awareness comes in, I guess.
But it's just such an
ensemble, I don't really
feel like, oh, I'm like the
adult playing the adult here.
But yeah.
Did I answer your question?
CORRIE DAVIDSON: No,
you mentioned you're
a deputy and a fire warden?
Like, what?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARINDA ANDERSON: I am that too.
I am a fire warden.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Just
hold it very well.
MARINDA ANDERSON: No, we are
in a union, the actors equity
union.
And each show has a deputy.
So it's like if anything,
any troubles arise,
they come to me.
And I told them,
don't come to me.
Don't do it.
But it's always that
thing at the beginning
of rehearsals, they're like,
who wants to be the deputy?
And everyone's like, well,
yeah, I did it before.
I don't really need
to do it again.
So I just went ahead
and volunteered.
And then I also became
the fight captain
to make sure people stay safe.
There are a few little
tiffs in the show.
So I just make
sure we stay safe.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Gotcha.
Gotcha.
Now, you had
mentioned earlier, you
have a fight call
earlier before the show.
And there are some fight
scenes, some dance scenes.
There's a lot of choreographed
elements for this show.
What kind of special
training did you guys
have to go through
to prepare for that?
The choreographers
you brought in,
what was that experience like?
GREGG MOZGALA: Well, we
have a-- so neither Tiffany
nor I have a dance background.
MARINDA ANDERSON: Professional
dancers are nowhere.
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah, right.
Right.
But I mean, I have
had experience.
I was in a dance piece
several years ago.
But that was it.
I mean, I was hired as an
actor to be in that dance piece
and had to learn
all those skills.
But this was a very
different style.
I mean, all great
high school stories
should end at a
high school dance.
And you know,
"Teenage Dick" does.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Yes.
GREGG MOZGALA: And so--
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
You want [INAUDIBLE]..
GREGG MOZGALA: I mean,
again, you saw in that scene,
it's like their relationship,
most of their scenes
take place within Anne's dance
studio, where she is teaching
Richard how to dance.
And they meet through the body.
And I think it's
really beautiful,
Mike, what he's constructed
here, because they develop
this really incredible
level of intimacy that
later becomes sort of romantic,
but doesn't start that way.
But yeah, we had two incredible
choreographers, Jen Weber,
who worked on a Ma-Yi
production of "KPOP,"
which was about Korean
pop, the Korean pop scene.
And Liz Tenuto, the
associate choreographer.
And we just--
TIFFANY VILLARIN: We
started every rehearsal
with 90 minutes of dance.
So the first week, I was like,
oh, my god, these muscles--
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah,
we were hurting.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: --that
I've never felt before.
You know?
And now, we've just built it up.
We're like, OK, I can do this.
Yeah.
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah.
But again, I mean,
the difference
between dancers and
actors is dancers practice
their craft every day.
If you're not in a show, you
go to the barre, and like,
you take a class.
Actors aren't that disciplined.
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
We also go to a bar.
GREGG MOZGALA: Right!
[LAUGHTER]
Exactly.
Right.
Yeah.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Marinda
and I were at the bar
while you guys--
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Yes.
While we were rehearsing,
they were at the bar.
MARINDA ANDERSON:
We were brunching.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Yeah,
explain them later.
GREGG MOZGALA: We come from
a long line of people who
have never picked up a fork.
So yeah.
It's just another element
to the play, again,
I think because of the
high school nature of it,
the ending at prom, or like the
big spring fling, or whatever.
You know, you have to have that.
And Mike said, in a
conversation the other day,
because "Richard III" ends at--
the Battle of Bosworth is
the big climactic event.
And so he said he
was transplanting
the world of the
high school dance
into the Shakespearean battle.
And I thought that was
really, really amazing.
I just really lived that idea.
So yeah, we drilled, and
drilled, and drilled.
CORRIE DAVIDSON:
Actually, movement
is such a theme of the
show in different ways.
Actually, Shannon, I know--
we talked about this earlier,
but you had a really funny
role on the Hulu show, RIP,
"Difficult People"--
we'll pour one out for
that really, they cast
you as a comedian.
And it was written for
someone in a wheelchair.
It was cast for a comedian.
And then in this role, Buck is
traditionally played by a man.
And you're playing
it as a woman.
SHANNON DEVIDO: It
was originally a man.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Yes.
MARINDA ANDERSON: A little boy.
SHANNON DEVIDO: A
very little boy.
GREGG MOZGALA: Right, well, I
had known Shannon for a couple
years prior to this.
And Mike did not know her.
So she was always, from
the genesis, it was like,
we're going to use
Shannon DeVido.
But I think Mike wasn't sure.
But as soon as he discovered
how wonderful Shannon was,
it was a match.
SHANNON DEVIDO: I was
allowed to be in the room.
CORRIE DAVIDSON:
You were allowed.
[LAUGHTER]
So in this show, you bring
this robust reinterpretation
to the role.
And you were cast for
your talents as an actor.
But you bring these
really wonderful, almost a
secondary character
with you to the stage.
And we've brought
up before, Shannon
has this great scene, where
she's giving Richard the finger
and rolling away.
And it's just this epic fade.
And it's such a--
It's really, really well done.
Your comedic timing
is so on point.
So how did you bring that
unique choreography to the role?
And how did you work
with the other actors
and the choreographers
to stage that?
SHANNON DEVIDO: That's a
very interesting question
because I don't think about it.
I didn't really work with
the choreographers at all.
It's funny because
a lot of the reviews
also touched on that,
how it's just part
of the world of how I live.
And I love that they are seeing
that because a wheelchair is
often put into this world
where it's a hindrance,
or "wheelchair bound" is
often a term that is used,
but we need to stop using.
But it is.
Like you're tied to it, and
it's this horrible thing.
But I love that people are
noticing that it's so freeing,
and it's a part of me.
And I don't-- it
flows through me.
Actors often talk about
being in their bodies when
they're acting.
And I feel like, for
so many years, when
I was in acting
classes, they wanted
me to be in just my body.
And I appreciate that.
But I feel like my wheelchair's
an extension of that.
And I really get the
ability to utilize that
on the stage in this show.
And I think a lot of my comedy
comes through with that.
So yeah, it's pretty cool that I
got that ability to show people
that it's not a hindrance.
It's actually a freeing,
wonderful thing.
GREGG MOZGALA: Can I add
to that a little bit?
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Absolutely.
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah, the
comment on how people
respond to the reviews is--
the reviews have been fantastic.
But again, people are
amazed that I can dance.
I'm not sort of
calling anybody out.
But this sort of idea, I think
it's just you haven't seen it.
There are plenty of
amazing actors and dancers.
There's a dancer named
Alice Sheppard, who's
a wheelchair dancers, who is on
the cover of "Dance" magazine
this month.
You just haven't-- it's
not in cultural zeitgeist.
It hasn't been shared
or displayed as much.
So it's so new, it's
almost revelatory.
And again, the
sort of vocabulary,
the language about
having to write,
I think if you just saw it more
and more and more and more,
that would fade away, and
people would just say,
Shannon is like a physical
and verbal comedic actor.
And she has a great
genius in that sense.
And I consider myself a
rigorous physical actor
because I mean, I throw
myself around all the time.
But people seem so
amazed that I-- and it's
a common conception about
disability in some ways, that
you you can get to the store,
or like, get to your job,
or have a life, or whatnot.
And if the theater is just sort
of a reflection of our lives,
then oh, my god, look what
these people can do on stage--
I think that's why having
the narratives that
are more nuanced, more
thought out, again,
where the disabled people
themselves have agency and can
inhabit roles that are
closer to themselves
actually help to move
that needle forward.
And it starts a discussion.
I mean, we're having
a discussion right
now about this.
Right?
And this discussion itself
is pretty unprecedented.
Like, I never imagined I
would be at Google, talking
about a play that came to life
with these incredible people.
You know?
But again, it's about proximity,
and it's just about visibility.
And again, why, I
think Ma-Yi and work
within the
African-American community,
within the theater community,
any marginalized group,
they understood, we have
to tell our own stories.
Or our own stories in
partnership with others.
The plays, and the
plays and the plays
and the plays, that
the narrative is what
moves the culture forward
and then hopefully society
forward too.
But it's working well together.
They're both moving like this.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: You
mentioned agency,
which is actually something I'd
like to talk to Tiffany about.
Women in Shakespearean plays
are often side characters.
Particularly in
"Richard III," they
tend to fill a role of a
crying, mourning victim.
Mike wrote these roles
very differently.
He gave a lot of meat to
your role in particular.
And as the play
goes, your character
changes the tone and the
direction of some of the show.
Without revealing
anything, how did you
bring that agency and ultimately
that power to your role
as Anne?
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Again,
I think this roots
to being able to be in
the room with a new play
at the inception,
or very near to,
and having relationships with
playwrights who are alive
and like writing
for you in a way.
Shakespeare died so long ago.
And he didn't write
anything for me, I feel.
But getting to sit with
Mike and saying, like,
hey, I think she's
smarter than that, I think
she's got more grit than we--
we were able to have
those conversations.
And Mike is the
kind of playwright
who's open to having
that with all of us
about all of the roles
about what we think
is authentic to that character.
And we were getting
rewrites and previews.
We got a whole new scene.
We'd already done three
previews, and got a new scene,
and put it up.
And I feel very blessed
to be able to stand
on the public stage and say
something like, "I am not
a tossed off afterthought
like in a Shakespeare play,
where all the women are a
bunch of objects, and character
foils, and plot devices."
And I get to do that,
and I get to say that,
and look at women
in the audience
and see it reflected back to me.
And that, I think, is a
really special moment,
and something that is
under the whole piece,
this idea of agency.
And something we
talked about, too,
Mike started writing this
play four or five years ago
before this big
cultural turn that we've
had in the MeToo
movement and all of that.
And Mike has a lot of pop
culture references in his play,
plays that change, that
keep changing with time.
And that's another thing,
Delivering that monologue now
is different than when I did
it in a workshop two years ago.
And getting to dig into it in
those layers is very powerful,
I think, and feels good.
It's something that I think
needs to be seen onstage.
Yeah.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: You
mentioned the we're
still getting new scenes
and line changes up
through previews.
And I know you and Marinda
have actually have both done--
and Shannon too--
have both done TV.
Both of you were on "Gotham."
I don't know if there
was any overlap there.
But how is that
process from doing
TV, episodic TV, or one-off
roles compared to live theater?
I know you've also
done multi-format work?
But what is that process
like that's different?
MARINDA ANDERSON:
I love theater.
I mean, there's nothing like it.
TV is cool too.
[LAUGHTER]
It is very cool.
I mean, I want to do
more of it as well.
And I mean, everyone
gets to see it.
You get more exposure,
whatever, that way as well.
I mean, I love both mediums.
But theater, just
to be with people.
It's about community,
and reaching, people,
and it's making contact that
you can't do through a screen.
And the preparation
is totally different.
I get so nervous if I
have to be on a set.
It's like, just know your lines,
and just say your two lines.
Mr. President!
[LAUGHTER]
Or whatever.
And it's actually very
nerve-wracking to me sometimes.
But with theater,
I mean, it's alive.
And the great thing is
these two, they're so good.
He is so good, like, just
being spontaneous on the spot.
He responds in the audience.
Someone sneezed, and
he was like, bless you.
You know what I mean?
You can do.
And that's so amazing.
And I love it.
It makes me so excited
when those things happen.
Yeah.
So that's how I feel about it.
Anybody else want
to talk about it?
CORRIE DAVIDSON: So speaking
of multi-formats, Shannon,
when are we going to get more
installations in your YouTube
series?
SHANNON DEVIDO: [LAUGHS]
CORRIE DAVIDSON:
Actually, why don't you
tell everyone-- give us a
little background on why
you created that, what
you were doing with it.
And then tell me when
we get more episodes.
SHANNON DEVIDO: So I have
a web series on YouTube
called "Stare at Shannon."
And I started it
because I was bored.
And I was like, hey,
it'd be really funny
if I went through a
drive-through in my wheelchair
and filmed it.
And then I called my friend.
I was like, can you do this?
And he was like, uh, sure.
And so he did.
And so we went through the
drive-through in my wheelchair,
and Jerry filmed it.
And then I was like, oh,
I should do more of this
because I'm bored a lot.
But in reality, the reason
I wanted to do was because--
I have this phrase
where I'm like, well,
people are staring at me anyway.
I might as well be
doing something cool.
And so yeah, so I do all
kinds of weird things,
like go to a grocery
store, and eat food,
and see what I
can get away with.
[LAUGHTER]
Which is true.
I did.
I was very sick.
Because I ate everything.
I ate a cake.
I made a--
GREGG MOZGALA:
Nobody stopped you?
SHANNON DEVIDO: No.
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
Did you have to pay?
You just opened it up?
SHANNON DEVIDO: I paid
at the end, yeah, yeah.
So I mean-- no, yeah, so I
just like kept opening stuff.
And like, the
people at the store
would help me [INAUDIBLE].
I made a sundae.
I poured a bowl of cereal.
I just made a sandwich.
I just went to town.
And no one stopped me.
They all helped.
I just was like, all right.
And oh, god, painful.
I ate a whole cake.
It was ridiculous.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Hilarious.
GREGG MOZGALA: Do
you take suggestions?
SHANNON DEVIDO:
Yeah, no, I just--
yeah, OK.
I was fun though.
But you watch that
on YouTube and then
think about how sick I was.
So anyway, so that's my channel.
I'm really selling it.
When will you get more?
Well, I'm here a lot.
So I'm not bored.
But I'll be bored.
I'll be bored on July 30.
So maybe then I
will have some time
to eat more food
in a grocery store.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: I
look forward to it.
GREGG MOZGALA: But
Shannon, you said something
earlier about using
comedy as a vehicle
to move things forward,
or spark the conversation,
or it makes it
easier to metabolize
the issues around the issues.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Yeah,
well, I mean, disability
is not a fun thing to talk
about, which you definitely
touched on earlier.
It's like, that's sad.
Right?
But comedy is not.
So sometimes.
It depends on how good you are.
[LAUGHTER]
Sometimes it's [INAUDIBLE].
I have been in a lot of improv
shows that were very sad.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: And you
have an improv group.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Yeah,
I've been in a couple,
and a couple sketch groups.
So there's a lot of
sad comedy going on.
But it does.
It's a very good way to
break down a barrier that
is not fun to talk about.
And it allows you to talk
about what you're doing
versus the disability of it.
I think that people
are then seeing me
as a comedian versus seeing
my chair first and then
a comedian.
So yeah, I like company
for that reason.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Wonderful.
At this point, we're
going to open it up
to audience questions.
We have a microphone
in each aisle,
if you want to approach
the microphone.
And we'll do Q&A. While people--
they're going to ask questions.
While people are doing
that, I have a couple
of fun rapid fire questions.
We'll burn through
them pretty quickly.
GREGG MOZGALA: Can I say just
one thing about questions,
though?
I mean, one thing
that I say to anyone
is ask whatever
you want, and then
anything you're afraid
ask, don't be afraid.
We'll answer anything.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Or Gregg will.
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
Right, Gregg will.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Gregg will.
GREGG MOZGALA: There you go.
So go for it.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: OK.
Who is most likely to
try and get everyone
to go out and party after
a show or a practice?
[LAUGHTER]
SHANNON DEVIDO: Not me.
I want to train.
MARINDA ANDERSON:
I feel like Gregg.
GREGG MOZGALA: What?
MARINDA ANDERSON:
You the one who
wanted [INAUDIBLE] last night.
GREGG MOZGALA: So Alex
Breaux plays Eddie.
And he couldn't be here today.
It was just the two of us.
And--
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Guys.
GREGG MOZGALA: You
know, we're guys.
And we're doing our thing.
And the ladies are just
like putting on music,
and we hear them laughing.
They're having a great time.
They have a case of rose
in their dressing room.
I don't think they're
drinking before the show,
but after the show, for sure.
MARINDA ANDERSON: As deputy,
you can have one beverage.
Before a show.
It's true.
It's in the rider.
Yeah, I knew that.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: I
have a questions.
So what book are you
reading right now?
MARINDA ANDERSON: Oh, I'm
reading "The Alchemist."
I'm slowly reading it.
But yes, I'm reading
that right now.
I'm almost done.
It's good.
I came late to that trend.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: [INAUDIBLE],,
I think we have a question.
AUDIENCE: Great job, you guys.
Now I feel like I've
got to go see the show.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Yes!
AUDIENCE: So this question,
really could be for anybody.
But you mentioned doing ad
libs and being really present.
And I was curious in particular
for Shannon, like, wheelchairs,
they can break down some times.
And you get equipment
failure, and stuff happens.
And I thought it was
really cool in that scene
how you used it for a
really good comic effect,
like Corrie was saying,
going back and forth.
But do you ever--
your battery runs out in
the middle of a scene,
or you get a flat tire?
Has that ever happened?
SHANNON DEVIDO: I am
solid rubber tires.
So I make sure that
doesn't happen.
Well, one thing that
was crazy in the show
is we got a veneer
put onto the stage.
And so my wheels
were crazy squeaky.
And it was so terrible.
I definitely was like
the center of the show.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: But it
was also our tennis shoes--
SHANNON DEVIDO: Yeah,
whatever it was, it was bad.
It was bad news bears.
But that was a little stressful.
But no, my battery
has never died.
I had to get wheelchair repairs
that my insurance wouldn't
pay for.
But that was a stressful time.
That has nothing to
do with the show.
I don't know why
I brought that up.
It's fine now.
Oh, god.
I hate it.
I hate talking.
I'm so glad I'm an actor.
[LAUGHTER]
No, my wheel gets caught on
the stage a bunch of times.
And I just kind
of push through it
and pretend it didn't happen.
That's a great answer
to your question.
I'm so sorry.
I apologize.
AUDIENCE: I'm sure it will.
Do you ever feel like you
have to educate other people?
Like if you fall out
of your chair, which
does happen from time to
time, before you realize like,
you're OK, but
then everyone else
is going to get freaked out.
And your main job is to
reassure them, this is OK.
This happens.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Oh, wow.
AUDIENCE: You ever had
that kind of feeling
about that particular
thing happening,
or other stuff like that?
SHANNON DEVIDO: No.
No.
I wear a seat belt. I have seen
people fall out of their chair.
I have never fallen
out of my chair.
Knock on wood somewhere.
Yeah.
No, Gregg and I have
talked about this a bunch.
We were in rehearsals,
and we would allow anyone
to ask us questions
because you do often
have to educate because it's
just so many people around.
And we went out to lunch.
And I am Marinda and Sasha we're
talking about how they never
really noticed how many
stairs there are in the city
because it's just now
something you realize.
I realize it every day
when I'm in the elevators.
And it's just kind of
that stuff that yes, I
feel like there is an
educational piece of it.
But it's not
something that I ever
feel burdened by or
anything like that.
I like having those
conversations, because it's--
Gregg can talk more about that.
But I'd rather you ask me
than don't and just assume.
Because we all know that phrase.
Am I allowed to
say ask at Google?
Well, I just did.
[LAUGHTER]
GREGG MOZGALA: No.
But what I think what
you just mentioned is--
I mean, I'm not a
wheelchair user,
but again, I am constantly
negotiating that relationship.
It's like any time
I meet someone new,
we do this sort of strange
social pas de deux,
where it's like,
I know you see me,
and you're clocking something.
And should we mention it?
And I put you at
ease and let you
know that I'm an actual person
that can talk, and whatever,
and do all these things?
And I think that's just
part of the experience.
But I'm actually fascinated
by that exchange.
And again, that's why I think
theater is a great vehicle
for this sort of
exploration, because you're--
we're always in relation to
an audience as disabled people
and negotiating that.
Theater is an explosion of that
idea, where there's a frame,
and you can have control over
the story that you're telling.
So I mean, that's just a way for
me to wrassle that beast down.
And again, I can choose where
I want to engage and disengage.
And I just happened
to start a company
where the whole purpose
is to be a platform
for the conversation.
So at this point in my life,
I may be talking more about it
more than I like or should,
but I think the need is there.
And again, what art
does, what theater
does in particular is create
a community, as Marinda said.
It creates an
opportunity to discuss.
Right?
And I think rather than say,
let's talk about disability,
we're talking about
this particular play,
where disability and several
other issues are present.
You know?
So if it comes up,
we'll talk about it.
And if not, we'll also
just talk about the play.
I'm really interested in that
sort of overlap, that exchange,
and that synergy.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Wonderful.
I think we have a question here.
Maddie?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you guys again
so much for coming.
We're all so excited
to have you here.
So you've already answered
this question a little bit.
But I was really excited to ask.
But I wanted to talk again about
using comedy as a storytelling
device, because the show seems
so funny, while also tackling
really difficult issues.
I just wanted to ask if there
were any challenges with that,
or if there is any worry that
the audience may misinterpret
jokes, or if you
were ever worried
about trivializing anything.
So that's my question.
GREGG MOZGALA: Marinda?
Marinda?
MARINDA ANDERSON: No.
AUDIENCE: You can just refuse.
GREGG MOZGALA: No.
[LAUGHTER]
No, like again--
I think just for myself,
and it was a conversation
with Mike and Moritz, the
director, and everyone,
we opened it to the cast.
Like again, we're
hitting on things.
There's some language that
might be considered offensive
in this show.
But everybody's fair
game, basically.
And for the comedy
to be successful,
you really have to lean into it.
You can't shy away from it.
You have to be as mean,
or rude, or insensitive
through the character.
Right?
Because it's a very respectful
ensemble of wonderful people.
But I think in order
for that comedy to work,
it has to be played seriously
and for all it's worth.
So again, we had to
have those discussions.
And I think that everyone on
that stage and in the process
is game to do that.
If someone wasn't, then they
wouldn't be involved in this.
I mean, that's intentional,
again, from my point of view,
to really tackle that.
And we are getting laughs.
It's a funny, funny play.
And Mike has done
a fantastic job.
And what that does
is bring people in
and gets people on our side
until the great dramatic--
TIFFANY VILLARIN: So then we
can punch them in the gut later!
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah!
You know?
But hopefully, it gets people.
I mean, again, Ma-Yi had a
benefit night Tuesday night.
And again, we had
this wonderful talk.
This woman really articulated
her whole emotional process
throughout the play of
being able to laugh,
and then feeling conflicted.
But it got her thinking,
and it got her thinking
in a new way, which,
regardless of the subject
matter, any great
piece of art should do.
That's the desired effect.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Thanks.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: So back
to a couple of questions.
Again, feel free to approach
the mic if you haven't yet.
What are your
greatest extravagance?
Like, what is that
thing that you're
going to splurge on or
treat yourself with?
MARINDA ANDERSON:
I'm going to Jamaica.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Yes.
Well done.
MARINDA ANDERSON: I
booked it for the 30th.
So the day after we close,
I am on a flight to Jamaica.
I'm taking myself for
my birthday because.
GREGG MOZGALA:
When's your birthday?
MARINDA ANDERSON: July 17.
GREGG MOZGALA: OK.
MARINDA ANDERSON:
I accept gifts.
Yeah.
GREGG MOZGALA: That's right.
MARINDA ANDERSON: Yes.
Yes.
And so that's my
extravagance right now.
And it's great.
It's great to have
a vacation planned.
I never really do that.
And it's something
to look forward to.
So I recommend.
I'm glad I was able to do that.
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: What is a word
or phrase that you overuse?
SHANNON DEVIDO: Probably
so many of them.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: I think I
say "indeed" a lot, indeed.
Like I say that, just like that.
Yeah.
MARINDA ANDERSON: I don't
know if I've heard you--
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Have
you heard me say that?
SHANNON DEVIDO: No, maybe
you don't do that because I
have never heard you say it.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Oh,
I used to say that.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Just now.
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
Maybe just in my head.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Whoa.
[LAUGHTER]
CORRIE DAVIDSON:
Or a word or phrase
you think other people overuse
that kind of grinds you.
MARINDA ANDERSON:
Oh, I overuse yoss.
I say yoss to everything.
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
I feel supported
when you say that to me.
MARINDA ANDERSON:
Oh, well, good.
That's why I say it.
It is a support.
It's affirmation.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: It is.
It is.
MARINDA ANDERSON: All of the
above It's like, you go, girl.
It's everything.
So that's why.
And I use it for
everything, so yoss.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: [LAUGHS]
MARINDA ANDERSON: So
probably too much.
CORRIE DAVIDSON:
Oh, [INAUDIBLE]..
What's the best gift
you've ever gotten?
I know you're giving
yourself the gift of Jamaica.
MARINDA ANDERSON: Yes.
That's it.
Thank you.
You answered my question.
you answered your question.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: You're
about to have a kid.
GREGG MOZGALA: I know.
I'm about to have a kid.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
You know, I was
thinking it, but I
didn't want to go there
because that's over--
people always say that.
No.
MARINDA ANDERSON: You have to
be like, oh, my kid is the best
thing.
GREGG MOZGALA: No, my wife
and I are setting up first.
She's due end of August.
So yeah, that's
pretty freaking cool.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: All right.
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: If
you were a candy bar,
what candy bar would you be?
GREGG MOZGALA: Oh.
MARINDA ANDERSON: Does it
have to be a candy bar?
CORRIE DAVIDSON: No,
it can be any candy.
MARINDA ANDERSON: OK, Skittles.
GREGG MOZGALA: No.
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
Oh, yeah, love them.
I would be a dark chocolate bar
with almonds and a little sea
salt.
MARINDA ANDERSON: Almond Joy?
TIFFANY VILLARIN: No,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
Good dark chocolate,
like dark chocolate.
Yeah.
MARINDA ANDERSON: Mm, OK.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
GREGG MOZGALA: I'm not even
a fan of this candy bar,
but I would say a
Whatchamacallit.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: I love those.
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah?
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
And also Caramellos.
[LAUGHS]
GREGG MOZGALA: (SINGING)
Stretch it out, out, out.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: It's
just like caramel for days.
MARINDA ANDERSON: What's
in a Whatchamacallit?
GREGG MOZGALA: I
don't know, but it's--
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
It's like nougat.
GREGG MOZGALA: I feel like
that sort of sums up me.
MARINDA ANDERSON: OK.
GREGG MOZGALA: Right, exactly.
People are like, huh?
What is that?
MARINDA ANDERSON: I
mean, I can't even
remember the last time saw that.
GREGG MOZGALA: Like, weird.
I like it.
Do I like it?
I don't know.
You know?
Yeah.
What about you, Shannon?
SHANNON DEVIDO: Oh, gosh.
Well, I like so many candy bars.
That's the problem.
I think I'm just thinking
about all the candy
I want to eat right now.
I don't know.
I'd probably like a NutRageous
or something like that.
GREGG MOZGALA: Nice.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: A NutRageous.
MARINDA ANDERSON: Y'all
are bringing me back.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: It
had a red wrapper.
Right?
Or yellow-orange.
I don't remember.
SHANNON DEVIDO:
Yeah, I don't know.
Yeah something like that.
MARINDA ANDERSON:
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But Shannon also put me
onto the Smurfs gummies.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Oh,
gummy Smurfs, Haribo.
Dude, gummy Smurfs are the best.
Just FYI.
GREGG MOZGALA: Did those come
back because of the movies?
SHANNON DEVIDO: I don't know.
They're always in Five Below.
I just eat them.
GREGG MOZGALA: Oh.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: Oh, we
have another question.
AUDIENCE: So here's
my for a question.
Olivier or McKellen?
GREGG MOZGALA: Whoa.
MARINDA ANDERSON: Oh.
GREGG MOZGALA: As Richard
III, or just in general?
AUDIENCE: As Richard.
GREGG MOZGALA: Oh, man.
AUDIENCE: No, in all
seriousness though--
[LAUGHTER]
GREGG MOZGALA: Oh, OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Dude, we get to dodge that one.
AUDIENCE: So you're setting
this thing in high school
and having all of the
characters or most
of the characters as teenagers.
How do you think
that affected the way
that you're telling this story?
And probably also, do
you think that that
might overshadow the
message that you're
trying to send to some people?
TIFFANY VILLARIN:
That's a great question.
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: I think
that what we've found
and what's come up in
talkbacks is the high school
aspect about the show.
And I feel like we all had
that experience of high school,
and we all harbor traumas that
happened to us in high school.
And I imagine, being in
the audience for the show,
it all just comes
right back as soon
as you see the set, and the
lockers, and the backpacks.
And you're like, oh, I
remember that actually boy,
and I remember that weird girl.
I feel like it actually
puts those of us who've
been through high school back
on that playing field, where
we remember what the
stakes felt like,
and what it was like
to be unpopular,
and to want to be
powerful, and trying
to find a way to do that.
Now, actual high school kids,
I think, who've seen the show,
sometimes I feel like it's
too close to their reality
in a way, that as
adults, I think
we have the advantage of getting
to look back at it backwards.
But for them, it's
closer to the bone,
and interesting too in that
way, where it feels potent.
And Anne's storyline
in particular
is one that deals with--
no spoiler alerts--
but just deals
with some serious issues
for teenage girls.
GREGG MOZGALA: Issues
around sex and sexuality
in a very real way.
TIFFANY VILLARIN: And I had
a conversation with a younger
woman in high school
who saw the show,
and it was serious for her.
She was like, how did
you prepare for that?
How did-- you know?
I was like, oh, yeah,
thanks for reminding me.
This is reality out there.
So yeah.
That's a great question.
GREGG MOZGALA: I
mean, I would love
to see this play
performed by people
who are closer to the age,
if not the actual ages.
I think there's room for that.
But Mike and I
had-- the playwright
and I had a lot of
conversations back and forth
initially about who this
play is for and what
the type of audience is for.
And again, the age range
has been pretty broad.
But this is what the
version of this play
is now, for its premiere.
And it's based on
who started it.
And I mean, I was far too old
to play it when the show started
or was first commissioned.
But again, I think we agreed
because of Mike's language,
and people having an
availability and skill to do
that, we decided to go older.
But there are plenty of
talented younger people
who could certainly play it.
I think that would be
really interesting.
Now, what's great, this play
will be out in the world.
It has been launched.
Right?
And that would be
up to Mike to decide
whether, if anyone approaches
him, high school, or college,
or whatnot, to do that, he
can give his blessing or not.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I'm sure
high school would definitely
be willing to do this.
And I will also say, your story
about the squeaking wheels,
as a high schooler who did
have to actually carry around
disability equipment, yeah,
that would probably make
it a little bit more realistic.
SHANNON DEVIDO: [LAUGHS]
TIFFANY VILLARIN: Oh, you like
the element of the loud wheels.
SHANNON DEVIDO: It
was just very loud,
and you couldn't hear
anything I was saying.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that is a problem.
SHANNON DEVIDO:
That was very funny.
AUDIENCE: Definite-- that
would definitely help.
In my case, it was visual
impairment equipment.
It wasn't too in the way.
But it was definitely
a hallmark of me.
GREGG MOZGALA: Sure.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Yeah, sure.
GREGG MOZGALA: Very good.
SHANNON DEVIDO:
That's really good.
GREGG MOZGALA: Thank you.
CORRIE DAVIDSON:
You have to draw
that line between total
reality and then achieving
for the stage or dialogue.
SHANNON DEVIDO: We're not miked,
so it was a little too loud.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: So we
are actually at time.
I just want to say
thank you guys so
much for taking the time.
They have a show tonight
at the Public Theater.
I highly encourage you all--
get tickets.
Go watch the show.
GREGG MOZGALA: We're
running through July 29.
SHANNON DEVIDO: Yay.
GREGG MOZGALA: Yeah.
Come check us out.
CORRIE DAVIDSON: It's a really,
really wonderful funny show.
So thank you, guys.
GREGG MOZGALA: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]